Narrator:
Tonight, baseball legend
and prolific investor
Alex Rodriguez
returns to the Tank.
I love your story,
and it's so inspiring.
It reminds me of when I grew up.
Who's ready to raise the bar
with me and have a ball?
We are asking for $500,000
for 2% in our company.
Ouch.
Wow.
You're in the wrong place, okay?
I run a very lean business.
How can you sell it so cheap?
That's no margin.
Are you going to profit
from that enterprise?
I don't know the number off
the top of my head. I'm sorry.
This is a basic question
in investing.
There's no money in it.
Vegas: Before we jump
into the valuation,
do you guys want to drink
some beer?
Yes.
♪♪
Narrator:
First into the Tank is a product
that proves the old adage
"Practice makes perfect."
♪♪
Hey, Sharks.
My name is Thomas Fields,
and I'm the founder and CEO
of Grind.
Today, I'm seeking $250,000
in exchange for a 5% stake
in my company.
Now, millions of kids each year
dream of playing in the NBA.
Mark, I'm sure you were
one of them.
I was.
But whenever you get
to high school,
coaches usually expect you to
shoot up to 500 shots every day.
But usually this takes
about six hours at a time.
And good luck
trying to find somebody
to chase down your rebounds,
Mr. Wonderful.
It's not gonna happen.
That's why we created...
the Grind Machine,
the world's first
portable shooting machine
that captures your made
and missed shots,
automatically passes the ball
back out to you
and collapses down into the size
of a duffel bag
within 90 seconds.
Simply set up
our shooting machine
under any basketball goal,
and bam ‐‐
You're ready to lock in.
Our shooting machine rotates
190 degrees,
manually passing to
five positions on the court
so you can train
like a great athlete
from anywhere along the arc.
Unlike professional machines
that are sold to the Mavericks,
Grind is made for the consumer,
being the lowest‐cost machine
on the market today.
So, Sharks, who's ready to help
Grind develop interactive,
game‐changing products
one sport at a time?
Mark, you want to try it?
Cuban: Yeah. Love to.
Now, it's powered
by pneumatics, right?
So this is a completely new way
of passing the ball out.
So if you could stand, like,
right there.
Okay.
That's about right.
♪♪
Oh!
Oh, he sucks.
[ Laughter ]
Ready?
It should pass that out.
There you go.
♪♪
What is up
with that rim?
I hope the league
doesn't see this.
Wow.
He does suck.
♪♪
There we go. Finally.
Greiner:
Oh! That's what it took!
[ Laughs ]
Corcoran:
Thomas, what does it retail for?
We retail right now for $1,495.
What?
$1,495?
$1,495.
Okay.
So, Thomas, tell me a little bit
about your backstory.
You wanted to be an NBA player?
Fields: Yeah, absolutely.
So I grew up always wanting to
be an NBA player
and ultimately get my family
to a better means, right?
Growing up,
I saw my mom and my dad
always working 5:00 a. m. jobs,
night‐shift jobs.
So my goal was to get
a D‐1 scholarship, right,
and go to the NBA,
just like all the other kids.
Well, I blew out my ACL
four times...
Ooh.
...before graduating
high school.
Wow.
Rodriguez: Wow.
And I soon realized
that that dream
of getting to that next level
was not gonna happen.
And throughout
this whole process,
I realized that I was knocking
on the door at the gym
at 5:00 in the morning,
trying to use
the shooting machine
that my school purchased
that was $6,000, right,
and 400 pounds.
And I couldn't get in the gym.
It wasn't accessible to me
at the time, right?
I tried to buy one
for our house,
and it was like five, six grand.
So there was no way my family
was purchasing one.
And at that point, I realized
that these companies are really
overlooking the market.
So we came into the market
for $1,495,
and we're the first company
that started payment‐plan
solutions for individuals.
How much money did you put into
it to get it up off the ground?
$15,000.
And how did you earn
that $15,000, Thomas?
YMCA. Shoveling mud.
Everything that you can
think of, like ‐‐
Nice.
Fields:
I was putting it all in.
Thomas, what are your sales?
We launched March 1st of 2020.
So in five months, we presold
$215,000 worth of units.
Wow.
So that was on
a Kickstarter or...
No. So, we actually launched
pure e‐commerce on our website.
So what were you doing
to get people to know
about your product?
We started completely
word of mouth.
And as you know, in basketball,
it's a community
where if somebody says something
or there's a video out about it,
it goes pretty viral, right?
Right, so all the kids
on Instagram
who are shooting, right,
they put this
into an Instagram video
to show
how they're working out.
All the kids that watch that
think, "Okay.
If they're using it,
then it's cool for me."
Exactly. Exactly.
O'Leary: I'm not clear.
Have they actually been shipped
and are being used,
or is this preorder stuff?
Fields: This is preorders.
Everybody has paid us up front.
Okay. The product's not
in the market yet.
But how many units is that?
How many units?
125 units.
And not one
has been delivered yet?
Right.
This is our testing unit.
We've gotten here with $215,000
in sales through a pandemic
with no working capital,
all with one unit.
What's it cost you
to make a unit?
$977.
Oh, wow.
Wow.
Right.
So we have roughly 35% margins.
We think that at scale,
we could bring that margin down.
Cuban:
And what about power?
If I take it to the park
and just want to shoot,
what about power?
Yeah. Yeah.
So how long
does the power last?
It does need to be plugged in,
but version two,
that's exactly what we're on.
Okay.
So that's a challenge, right?
Yeah.
That makes it more
for the backyard
or the bucket you have
in your driveway.
Yep.
Right?
And it really doesn't help you
in terms of going to the park.
Some parks
actually do have outlets.
Have power?
Yeah.
You'd be surprised how many do.
Look, I go out
and I still shoot, right?
'Cause of quarantine, right?
That's how I clear my head.
It sure didn't show
in shooting those baskets.
Yeah. Trust me.
That should clutter
your head.
I can shoot.
But, you know...
There are other options
that are low cost, right?
So, there's just the metal rack
that just, you know...
Yeah.
...if you're
just shooting
and it just rolls right back
to you, that costs a lot less.
Now, every basketball player
will tell you they hate that.
Well, yeah, but I like $1,500
more than I hate...
Mark, what do you guys have
with the Mavericks?
Yeah.
It's a whole different level.
So, let me give you
the comparison, right?
So, if you're outside
shooting by yourself,
it's gonna take about six hours
to get up to 500 shots in,
right?
Versus our machine,
you can do that within an hour.
O'Leary: So, Thomas,
let me take a stab at this.
When I first saw the pitch
and watched Mark miss basket
after basket,
I thought to myself,
"You know,
this is a crazy idea
without any merit."
But the more I heard the story
and the fact
that you actually sold
over $200,000 worth of them,
that is more impressive.
This isn't a product for me,
though,
but we do have a token NBA owner
we keep on the side
here at "Shark Tank."
But I applaud you.
This is a cool product.
Means a lot coming from you.
But I'm out.
Greiner:
Listen, Thomas.
I think
it's a great idea.
I think it's very useful.
I'm just not a "sporty girl."
You know? So as an investment,
it's not the right one for me.
So for that reason,
I'm out.
Thank you, Lori.
Thomas, I got to tell you,
I love your story,
and it's so inspiring.
It reminds me
of when I grew up.
A kid from
the Boys and Girls Club ‐‐
I think it's fantastic.
I love the name Grind.
I love your grit.
For me,
I'm having a problem
with those margins
and the price.
For those reasons,
I'm out.
Thank you.
Look, the challenge is
right now, one, the valuation.
Okay. Yeah.
Right?
Two, your margins and how many
you can actually make
and how many
you can actually sell.
Yeah.
I love the, you know,
just grinding all your life.
That's who you are.
Absolutely.
And I respect that.
What you've been able
to accomplish is awesome.
Um, I'm just...
Yeah, let's negotiate, Mark.
Let's ‐‐ Let's figure this out.
Because I think this
can easily go to a $5 million
to $10 million company.
I'm not sure.
That's the question.
I'm not sure of that.
Right?
I‐I am.
No entrepreneur doesn't
think so, right?
I got you.
You know?
Absolutely.
You know, it's kind of scary
to sit next to him,
and he's not sure, and he's not
buying, and I'm wondering ‐‐
No. No.
Let me just tell you.
The minute you walk out that
door, with or without a deal,
I'm gonna buy one
for my backyard.
He's not here for one sale.
What are you doing, Mark?
[ Suspenseful music plays ]
Narrator: Three Sharks are out,
and Mark is undecided
about Thomas'
basketball shooting aid, Grind.
Cuban: Look, the minute
you walk out that door,
with or without a deal, I'm
gonna buy one for my backyard.
He's not here for one sale.
What are you doing, Mark?
Are you gonna make an offer?
'Cause I would like
to address it.
Such a good item, Mark.
I'm thinking
about it, yeah.
Yeah.
Thomas, I think your price point
is too high.
I think your product
is too ugly, all right?
If my neighbor put that in their
driveway, I'd kill them.
That's the truth.
I...
So I don't know what you could
do to make it look better,
but I think
it's got to look better.
We're going ‐‐ We're going for
a very mechanical,
straightforward ‐‐
Corcoran: Well, you've seen it.
It looks mechanical.
But I'll tell you,
I think you're a phenomenal
entrepreneur.
You got the whole package.
I would like to make you
an offer,
but I don't want to go in
without one of these
sports guys, okay?
One, because I want to use
their money
and two, because they know
what they're doing
in the sports field and I don't.
So I'm anxious to see if...
So, what do you have in mind,
Barbara?
So I'm thinking I would offer
$250,000 for 20%.
It's not enough.
You don't think
that's enough?
Yeah. It's not enough.
Oh, then I agree
with my partner here, Mark.
He's gonna ask you
for more.
What are you thinking, Mark?
So if there's two of us,
30%.
Okay.
I'll go with you.
I like your deal better.
So for two of us ‐‐
'Cause ‐‐ Let me just tell you.
And I know you think
it's a lot,
you know,
but it's not.
Period, end of story,
right?
Because Barbara's skill set
is her people skills.
And her ability
with the marketing and packaging
are better than mine.
I'm gonna make you pretty.
Yeah.
She'll make it pretty.
Let's do it.
So 250K for 30%.
I have a cap on myself, right?
So ‐‐
That's up to you.
'Cause it's
non‐negotiable.
Fields:
Non‐negotiable.
Rodriguez:
Thomas, before you decide ‐‐
You have one of the greatest
owners of the NBA.
I mean, this is a dream offer.
Let's do ‐‐
Let's do 25% for $300,000.
I think the valuation is ‐‐
is great for you guys, right?
I'm gonna take it
to a $10 million company
easily in two years, right?
What do you think, Barbara?
I'll work my tail off, right?
Let's get it.
Give him a sweeter deal.
Because I have to be a Shark,
250K for the 25%.
We got ‐‐ Let's get some ‐‐
Let's get some breathing room.
I just did, right?
I just did.
250K for 25%.
Be careful.
Now, if you're worrying
about 50K,
then you're not
valuing us.
[ Suspenseful music plays ]
Thomas, what are you
gonna do?
[ Sighs ]
If you have to think about it,
Thomas...
♪♪
Yeah. Let's do it.
Of course.
‐All right.
‐[ Sighs ] Good.
Whoa. I thought you were gonna
walk away. Whoof!
‐Yay. [ Laughs ]
‐Thank you, guys.
Love it. Good job.
All right. Thanks, guys.
Cuban: Well done.
Take care.
Congrats.
Fields: Man, I'm excited
about having Mark and Barbara.
I think we're gonna change
the world.
If you have a dream and you see
me up here making deals,
like, you can go do it
no matter where you're from.
♪♪
Narrator: In Season 11,
Mike Grice and Rob Neuner
made a deal with Kevin O'Leary
for their portable
oxygen canisters, Boost Oxygen.
We'll take the deal.
Herjavec: Lovely.
Let's see
what they're up to now.
Grice:
Boost Oxygen provides
nearly five times
the concentration of oxygen
than the air
that we're normally breathing.
Whether you're a senior citizen,
whether you're exercising,
whether you're an athlete,
we can all benefit
from the use
of supplemental oxygen.
The year that we pitched
the Sharks,
we did $6.4 million
in sales.
It's been less than a year
and a half since we aired,
and we've done
over $15 million in sales.
We've doubled, from 4,000
to over 8,000 locations,
where Boost Oxygen
is available ‐‐
Big 5 Sporting Goods,
Dick's Sporting Goods,
Kroger grocery stores,
Walgreens,
all the way down to those
individual mom‐and‐pop retailers
who recognize the value
of our brand
that they can bring
to their local consumers.
I used to drink coffee
in the afternoons.
Now in the afternoon...
[ Air hisses ]
...I Boost.
O'Leary: Boost Oxygen
is one of those deals
that you say to yourself,
"Why didn't I think of that?"
People have learned about it
all across America.
The brand is becoming
one of the best out there
in terms of helping athletes,
helping hikers,
helping people that work out.
I see this company being huge
in two years.
Look, we should all take
a moment and smell the roses.
Or better still, take a boost.
[ Both laugh ]
[ Air hisses ]
Neuner: Boost Oxygen
was started 14 years ago
in Bridgeport,
Connecticut.
And when the pandemic hit,
Bridgeport, being an inner city,
closed their schools,
and a lot of the school‐aged
children lost their access
to proper nutrition
during the day.
We wanted to help,
so we donated
to Connecticut Food Bank
of Bridgeport
to help provide meals
to the needy.
It's really inspirational
to be able to reach people
with a product
that didn't exist 14 years ago
and the millions of people
that now know about it
and rely on it
on a daily basis.
We're on the leading edge
of bringing
an entirely new idea forward,
and we're helping millions
of people as we do so.
[ Air hissing ]
♪♪
[ Dramatic music plays ]
Narrator: Next up is an easier
way to make healthy snacks.
♪♪
Hello, Sharks.
I'm Karen Nation
from Los Angeles, California,
and I'm here seeking $300,000
for 12% equity in my company.
I've dedicated my life
to nutrition
and found that people
really want to take back control
over what they put in their
bodies for healthier lives.
But when it comes to snacking
on nutrition bars,
the problem is there's way
too much sugar, preservatives,
poor‐quality ingredients.
And let's be honest.
They often taste unnatural.
So instead of eating expensive
candy bars in disguise,
I started making healthy,
homemade protein bites.
Sharks, I've reinvented
the snack game
with Creation Nation,
the world's first protein bar
and bite mixes.
It's no‐bake,
easy as a protein shake,
and even fun for kids to make.
Here's how it works.
Start by pouring
any of our mixes into a bowl.
Add your choice of liquid
to the mix,
then your favorite nut butter
or syrup.
One of the best parts
is you control the sugar.
So whether you're keto, paleo,
vegan, or gluten free,
personalizing your snack
is as easy as one, two, three.
All that's left to do is mix.
And then you're gonna roll...
...and take a bite.
That's cool.
Creation Nation is leading
a DIY snack revolution.
So who's ready to raise the bar
with me and have a ball?
Wow.
Rodriguez: Wow.
So, the ones on your left
were made keto style,
with just almond butter.
The energy bite mixes, we made
with peanut butter and honey.
Except for yours, Lori. There's
no peanut butter in yours.
Thank you.
Mark, all of yours
are our vegan mixes.
Cool.
And how much protein?
It's between 12
to 16 grams of protein
for a full‐size bar
or about five grams of protein
per ball.
Rodriguez:
They're very good.
They're actually
really good.
Very tasty.
So, how has the market
received this?
How are you selling?
So, we sell online.
One of our first retail partners
was one of the big
e‐commerce sellers.
Now we're also in Whole Foods
Market on the West Coast,
Costco in the Midwest,
and Walmart on the East Coast.
O'Leary:
Are these regional tests?
How come there's
no national rollouts?
Nation: Yeah, so ‐‐
We haven't gone national yet,
so we're still
in less than 500 stores.
What does it cost me
to buy this?
What does it cost you
to make it?
Nation:
So, it's $2.00 to $3.50,
depending on which product,
to make it.
And they retail between $7.00
and $11.00.
I'm wondering ‐‐ How did you
come up with this concept?
Well, I've really been obsessed
with nutrition
since I was a kid.
I spent some years
in the foster‐care system,
and the families really couldn't
accommodate my food allergies.
So I just didn't eat
or I ate a candy bar,
and I was constantly falling
asleep in class or always sick.
But I am
a very determined person,
and I pretty much self‐studied
my way to health
and later became certified
in sports nutrition.
Karen, why were you in
the foster‐care system,
and what was that like?
Well, um...
Well, yeah.
Family life at that time
wasn't a good situation,
so the courts decided
it was safer for me
to live in foster care.
The families were nice,
but it's, you know,
it's not your family.
It's not your home.
No. Of course.
It's definitely
very different.
One of the many jobs I held ‐‐
I was a house mother
for 14 children
in foster care.
And I had that job
for about a year and a half.
Wow.
And these kids developed
such a sense of value
that changed them forever.
You learn a lot
through that.
You learn to care for yourself,
I think.
Mm‐hmm.
What's revenue going to be
this calendar year?
At least $500,000.
We did $500,000 last year,
and we're set to do
at least that or more.
Well, you would hope you'd grow
year over year.
Was there any profits?
We're pretty much break even
all the time.
We run on cash flow.
Cuban: Are there other
no‐bake products?
No.
The question then becomes
why haven't you sold more?
Yeah.
What's holding you back?
We went to trade shows,
and we had all this interest,
all this momentum.
We hit a major
co‐packer problem.
They breached our contract
in a variety of ways.
I had very specific stipulations
about the shelf life
of the ingredient they were
putting in our product.
They didn't follow that.
So in other words, they
didn't follow your instruction,
you shipped out a bunch
with the ‐‐
let's call it
tainted product.
Correct.
And what happened?
So, we did a lot
of withdrawals.
It was just not
to our quality standards.
I pivoted quickly.
I got a new co‐packer
we've now been with
for a year and a half,
and they've been amazing.
By the end of last year,
we were doing great.
And then with COVID,
things kind of changed. Um ‐‐
So I pivoted again.
Why wouldn't this be
a great product for home
at COVID?
Yes.
So I pivoted our strategy
to e‐commerce,
and we've tripled our sales.
Wow. Good for you.
Rodriguez: Wow.
Last month, how much did you do
from wholesale?
We're about a 50/50 model
right now.
Just last month.
Last month.
I don't know the number off
the top of my head. I'm sorry.
Did you guys make money
last month?
Absolutely.
Yes.
We made about a total
of $30,000.
Good for you.
And what do you expect to make
by year end?
I'm expecting to do
at least $500,000.
We've already done $330,000 ‐‐
Money that you can take
as profit in your pocket.
Money you could put
in your pocket
and say, "Hey,
I got this money out."
If you're gonna sell $500,000 ‐‐
Not sales.
Not sales, but profits.
If you sell $500,000,
what will you have in the bank?
I‐I put the money
back into the business.
I mean, our margins are 40%
to 50%.
This is a basic question
in investing.
You're gonna sell $500,000 worth
of this stuff.
Are you going to profit
from that enterprise?
No. No. We ‐‐
Everything that we profit ‐‐
Took me a long time
to get that out of you.
I run a very lean business.
She's not answering.
Everything that we make,
we put back into marketing.
Listen. If you don't know what
the definition of profit is,
you're in the wrong place,
okay?
I...
I'm out.
Well, listen.
I like healthier food.
But sometimes I just go
with my gut.
I like the product.
I like you.
But I don't think it's
the right investment for me.
And so for that reason,
I'm out.
Thank you, Lori.
I appreciate it.
I really like your mission.
I like everything you stand for.
Your story is really amazing
and aspirational.
But when I look to invest
in a business,
I look for someone to know
the numbers inside and out.
So for those reasons,
I'm out.
Well, Karen,
you still have two Sharks in.
Barbara, do you like this
at all?
Barbara and Mark.
I love the product.
And just a piece of advice.
What frightens me ‐‐
If I'm gonna write you a check
for $300,000...
It's too high a price.
...and you're not remembering
the numbers,
that scares me.
Corcoran: Karen, Mark wants me
to go in on this deal,
but there's no money
in it.
And that's a basic requirement
I have for investing.
We have great margins.
Like ‐‐
But it doesn't find its way
into your pocket eventually
over the years so far.
I‐I must be missing
something basic, but I'm out.
This is a pantry staple
that bridges the gap
between nutritional powders
and grocery products ‐‐
Yeah.
Karen, I wish ‐‐
I'm trying to get there,
but I just can't.
The real product here
is fun,
but that's going to be
a lot of work.
So for those reasons, I'm out.
I'm sorry.
I know I'm gonna regret this,
but I'm out.
Thank you.
Congrats, Karen.
Congrats.
Terrific.
Congratulations.
♪♪
Ugh.
I'm a bit worried about her.
Rodriguez: I am too.
I think she's gonna take
this rejection pretty hard.
I'm gonna check up on her.
Oh, Barb.
Corcoran:
Wonder where she is.
Shark or no Shark, I'm gonna
keep doing what I'm doing.
And, you know, we have
first‐mover advantage here,
and I'm just gonna
keep going.
Yeah.
Hey, Karen.
I didn't want you to leave
here ‐‐ I hope you don't mind.
I didn't want you to leave here
thinking that you failed.
Thank you.
That you were able to stand up
to everybody was remarkable.
You've held your cool,
and you knew your numbers,
contrary to what Kevin
was saying.
I do.
So you should be walking
out of here
totally proud
of who you are.
Thank you, Barbara.
I really appreciate that.
I've worked really hard.
Because you're gonna inspire
everybody
who's watching the show.
You're gonna be shocked
at the inspiration
you're gonna provide people.
Okay.
Thank you, Barbara.
Yeah. Okay.
So walk out of here proud.
So great to meet you.
Having a Shark on my team
meant so much to me,
so I'm disappointed
that didn't happen.
But I'm just gonna keep going
and...
just keep going.
[ Laughs ]
[ Dramatic music plays ]
Narrator:
Next up is a better way
to keep your prized kicks
looking their best.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks. I'm Chris Pavlica
from Elmore, Ohio.
And I'm Kevin Consolo
from Chagrin Falls, Ohio.
And we're
the creators of...
...SneakErasers.
We're here
seeking $200,000
in exchange for 8%
of our business.
As we all know,
it's important to look good.
Barbara knows exactly
what we're talking about.
I like what you're talkin'.
[ Laughter ]
And for many, looking good
starts with their shoes.
That's right, Sharks.
People love the look of shoes
with new white midsoles.
But they're impossible
to keep clean!
We swear if you just look
at them wrong, they get dirty.
The second you leave the house
and step outside ‐‐
Not the driveway! ‐‐
You already
scuffed them up.
Or on a rainy day ‐‐
Watch out for that...mud puddle.
So unless you want to wear
a plastic bag over your shoes,
no one can tiptoe around
these elements
and avoid these disasters.
We knew there just had to be
a better way,
which is why we created...
SneakErasers.
Pavlica: This is a unique
dual‐sided sponge
engineered and designed
specifically for shoes.
You just tear open the pouch,
pull out the sponge,
and use the white side
to easily remove
all the scuff marks and dirt
and flip it over to the
orange side to wipe it clean.
And best of all,
it's premoistened,
so you can touch up your kicks
wherever you go.
And it works on all kinds
of shoes ‐‐ sneakers...
casual shoes...
sports cleats...
kids' shoes ‐‐
Okay. All right. All right.
You guys get the point.
So take these bad boys
with you
in your purse, your carry‐on,
your computer bag ‐‐
wherever you want to keep
your favorite pair
looking like new,
like before a job interview.
Or like before going
on a hot date.
Like with you, Barbara.
[ Laughter ]
So, who wants to kick it with us
and make millions?
Oh. I like that part.
Greiner:
Good job.
How many shoes
will one of these do?
It depends on the shoe.
We've gotten
up to like nine pairs.
No water needed?
Oh, no water needed. Yeah.
And that's
what really separates us.
What does the orange do?
The orange part is
a super‐soft chamois.
So it works on any delicate or
sensitive materials on the shoe.
And it also wipes away
just like a pencil eraser.
If you left any shavings behind,
it just wipes it clean.
Well, I have good news for you,
boys ‐‐ It works.
Oh, good. Good.
Thank you, sir.
Yeah, it does work.
What do you sell the three‐packs
for, and what does it cost you?
The three‐pack sells for $9.99,
and our cost is $1.98.
We do sell
the one‐count
in one of the largest retailers
in America ‐‐
that display right there ‐‐
and that's $3.99 MSRP.
How are the sales?
We have a lot of tests
that have gone very well.
For instance, that one retailer
started on a 100‐store test,
and we just rolled out
nationwide ‐‐ 2,800 stores.
Who was that retailer?
O'Leary:
And that was after how long?
That's Walmart.
How long did they test it for?
They tested it
for about four or five months.
It was just higher
than the buyers' expectations.
And we didn't know anything.
Neither of us are entrepreneurs.
We didn't have any experience
bringing a product to market.
We didn't know anything
about manufacturing.
about distribution
or how even
to do packaging.
So what is your story?
How did you learn?
The Internet.
And we just work our butts off
until we figure things out.
How much money have you invested
in the business?
I put my house behind it.
So I have a home‐equity
line of credit worth $300,000
that we've used to finance
these orders.
Greiner: Wow.
You are all‐in.
Yes, sir.
Yeah.
Hey, but we're debt free
as of last week.
We have no debt.
That's the big news.
You paid it down?
As of last week,
we are completely
debt free.
Rodriguez:
Nice job. Nice.
And we have some cash
in the bank.
What are your sales to date?
2019, we finished the year
at $202,000.
Wow.
Good for you.
And this year,
what do you think you'll do?
Year to date,
we're over $1.1 million...
What?!
...and we expect to do
$1.8 million.
Oh, my gosh.
Greiner: Wait.
So, I mean ‐‐
You know, that's a jump.
Our e‐commerce is about 12%
of our business.
We started putting focus
into that this year,
and already it's growing
exponentially,
matching
our retail business.
When we put money
into Amazon ads,
our total sales by month are
three times our ad spend.
Chris, what is your competition?
In terms of removing
scuff marks,
there are bulky brush kits
that are not very convenient.
You can't put them
in your pocket.
Spray foam.
They go everywhere.
Yeah. They're messy.
Fortunately, we do have
five different patents pending
across our line,
and we have been
knocked off once.
By us.
By our own product.
[ Laughter ]
So we made an economy line
and a premium line.
And what's the difference?
The big difference
are the pre‐moistened.
So, this is dry.
The user has to add water to it.
The density is different.
This has a scouring pad,
not a soft chamois.
You know, that's sold at dollar
and discount stores.
And we've sold 2.2 million units
of that already since October.
If I look at the two
beside each other,
do I know they're
the same company?
No.
This is Shoe Eraser, and our
premium brand is SneakErasers.
Well, good for you.
That's a first
in "Shark Tank" history.
I've never seen anybody
knock themselves off.
Thank you. Thank you.
Look, I like this story
'cause it's got sales, okay?
What I am surprised to hear
is that you're only 12% digital,
which is crazy
for a product like this.
This should be
50% direct to customer.
I'll make you an offer.
I'll give you $200,000 for 15%.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, Mr. Wonderful.
We're flattered
that you would give us an offer.
Appreciate it.
That's a little bit
more equity
than we want to give up
at this moment.
I think my name is a Shark.
Greiner: [ Laughs ]
Was that a no?
Guys, that there is a lot
to like here.
Thank you.
I wore cleats
for almost 25 years.
And there's nothing worse
than using your metal cleats
and have them be dirty, right?
It's a thing of pride.
That's something that
George Steinbrenner taught us.
Always make sure you shave,
cut your hair,
and clean your shoes, right?
But when I think about goals
and dreams, I like clarity.
What can we do for you
to take you from good to great?
It's about taking the skills
that you've already perfected
with advertising
and marketing.
Having that investment will
help us take our costs down
to increase our margins.
But it's also going to help us
launch our other brands.
So Golf Erasers
is already
our number‐one‐selling
e‐commerce item.
But it is to clean
golf club faces in between shots
and clean your shoes.
Oh, the face as well.
We want to tell you
about Auto Erasers, as well.
Auto Erasers is an instant
detailing sponge.
So, these are
already carried
in some of the largest retailers
in their sector.
When you were giving us
your sales numbers,
were they included,
or is that separate?
Yes. Yeah.
They are included.
All part of the company.
They're still only 5%
of our business.
When you came in here,
I got a little excited.
I saw a single product
that was selling like crazy,
two guys that had all the
skill sets to make it happen,
and then you started talking
about this other stuff.
And I realized
what I really have here
is guys who are inventors.
I'm never crazy about inventors
because the money
you make on this,
you lose on that.
You're all over the board.
I'm out.
Hey, Barbara,
thank you so much.
Greiner: Listen.
I think exactly...
Don't get discouraged.
...the opposite.
Thank you.
Because inventors
are the lifeblood
of innovation and products.
I've created over 800 on my own.
Brand extension's everything.
You get them to your website.
You have other things to offer.
You're just gonna add sales.
These aren't extensions.
They're whole other markets.
That's what's wrong.
Greiner:
So I like that you're inventors
and you also proved
that you're marketers.
O'Leary: And?
So you can do both.
Thank you.
So Alex and I were talking.
Yes.
And we were thinking
that we are going to give you
an offer together.
So it will be Alex and I
together.
It's going to be $200,000
for both of us but 20%.
Ouch.
Ichi‐ay caramba!
Thank you for your offer.
Because you got to make us
want to get out of bed
and go, "Hey. Let's get crackin'
on SneakErasers."
I understand.
All of a sudden,
the Mr. Wonderful offer
looks really attractive.
[ Laughing ] Yes.
Greiner: Not to us.
But what you need
is instant credibility,
and you need visibility.
Lori and I make a good team.
She takes care of e‐commerce.
I take care of bricks
and mortar.
And we want to put you
in over 500 gyms...
Wow.
...day one.
That's what we want to do
to get you started.
And then...
And I'll help you with, like,
the retail end
of the sporting‐goods stores.
I feel like you need to
blitz the market,
because you have a great
trademark, logo, and name.
Okay, Lori.
Let them make a decision here.
You've got two great offers.
And, Mark,
are you gonna do anything?
Say what?
Are you in or are you out?
Oh, I get to
ask questions now?
[ Laughs ]
Greiner: No.
Cuban: All right, guys.
Guys, look.
What does it cost you
just to make one of these?
Costs 59 cents.
Okay.
So ‐‐ And could you do one
with custom packaging?
Yes.
Yes. Of course.
Private label.
So if I wanted to offer one to
Mavs fans under the age of 20...
Absolutely.
...or if I wanted to
call up Nike
and say this should be bundled
and we can get it down
to 75 cents or whatever.
Yeah.
Okay.
So I'll make you an offer.
The $200,000 and I want 12.5%.
Okay.
But it's right now.
Thank you for this offer.
Greiner: No.
If you think that's right
and the right strategy ‐‐
You got 20% or 12%
with a guaranteed customer.
That's not the right strategy
for you guys.
Narrator:
One Shark is out.
Chris and Kevin have
three offers on the table
for their shoe‐cleaning company,
SneakErasers.
Kevin has offered $200,000
for 15%.
[ Laughs ]
Lori and Alex have offered
$200,000 for 20%,
and Mark has offered $200,000
for 12.5% of the company.
[ Whispering indistinctly ]
[ Suspenseful music plays ]
Okay. Sorry.
Sorry about that.
[ Whispering
indistinctly ]
Mark, would you up it
to $300,000 for 10%?
$300,000 for 10%?
Rodriguez: Wow.
I'm out, guys.
Corcoran: Wow.
Wise guy.
Who's the Shark now?
Guys, I'm not gonna do it
for less than 15%.
That's 20%.
What do you guys want to do?
Rodriguez: So, Lori, our offer
has to appear much nicer now,
now that Mark's out.
Well, our offer should have
appeared really nice
to begin with.
It is a fantastic offer.
Can you remind me
what your offer is? I'm sorry.
[ Laughter ]
I'm so sorry.
Cuban: Yeah!
Greiner: You forgot?
Is he always like this
when he gets nervous?
[ Laughing ] No.
Rodriguez: Here's our offer.
It's $200,000 for 20%.
O'Leary:
So you guys have a huge delta
between what your perceived
value is
and what Sharks think
you're worth.
Yeah.
We love the two Sharks.
Would you guys be willing
to come down in equity at all?
We thought 8% was a lot.
Would you bring it down at all?
No.
And I'll say this last thing,
because I'm about to take it
off the table.
We'll take it.
We'll take your deal.
[ Gasps, laughs ]
Corcoran: Wow.
Thank you.
Boom!
Oh. Well, boom.
Mark, we are so sorry.
Corcoran:
Closing line. [ Laughs ]
Cuban:
Congratulations, guys.
Greiner:
Congrats, guys.
Congrats. Great job, guys.
Aww.
Way to go, buddy.
Pavlica: It seems crazy to pass
up an offer from Mark Cuban,
but on the other hand, two
Sharks were going in together.
And it's exactly
what we needed ‐‐
a professional athlete
who everyone knows
and Lori,
who does everything that we need
to take us
to the next level.
It's just impossible
to pass up the both of them.
♪♪
[ Dramatic music plays ]
Narrator:
Next into the Tank
is a way to make home brewing
simpler.
♪♪
Hey, Sharks.
I'm Aaron.
And I'm Brett, and we're
from Boulder, Colorado.
We are asking for $500,000
for 2% in our company.
Ouch.
Wow.
Who doesn't love sipping
on an ice‐cold craft beer?
Am I right?
But the reason
why beer lovers everywhere
aren't making their own beer
at home
is 'cause it's not as easy
as it looks.
No. It takes tons of time,
experience, expertise.
And the worst part is
you can spend weeks
on a single batch of beer
and it can come out terrible.
That's why we've revolutionized
the craft‐beer‐making process,
taking home brewing
out of the basement
and turning beer lovers
into beer makers.
Introducing...
BeerMKR.
...BeerMKR.
This is the world's first
all‐in‐one
countertop
craft‐brewing appliance
that anybody can use.
Wow.
All right, Sharks.
Aaron and I are gonna quickly
walk you through a demo
of this product just to show you
how easy it is to use.
First thing you do
is you take your MKR Kit.
You connect the bag
into the machine,
open it all up,
pour in your grain.
The next step you do
is basically fill the entire
machine up with water,
close it all,
press the button on the front.
And over the next 24 hours,
BeerMKR is going to bring up the
temperature inside the machine,
mashing those grains and liquid
and creating wort,
which is a sugary liquid.
Next, you get a notification
on your phone,
and it says,
"It's time to put your yeast."
So open the machine
back up.
You pull out that basket
of spent grain.
You then put in your yeast,
you put in your hops,
close the machine back up,
press the button on the front.
And again, over the next five
to seven days,
BeerMKR is going to perfectly
control the pressure
and temperature
inside the unit.
Finally,
when that process is complete,
you get
another notification
saying it's time
to tap your beer.
So you remove the bag
of clean fermented beer,
bring it over
to your beer tap,
which is included
in the package,
simply install the bag of beer
inside the beer tap,
screw in the CO2 cartridge that
comes inside your MKR Kit.
And about a day later, you're
drinking cold, carbonated,
fresh, delicious craft beer
that you made yourself.
Corcoran:
Wow.
It was nine days
till I got a beer, right?
It depends on the recipe.
So each different type ‐‐
Do you see any problem
with that?
Rodriguez: No.
Greiner: Y‐‐ No.
No.
I mean, it's craft beer, Kevin.
You get a gallon of beer
as a result.
Okay, I guess it is worth
$25 million.
So, before we jump into
the valuation question,
do you guys want to drink
some beer?
Yes.
And ‐‐ And another question.
How many beers will you get
out of it?
So, BeerMKR makes
a 12‐pack of beer.
And the MKR Kits themselves
cost $15.
Hall:
So starting at the lightest ‐‐
That's our Future IPA.
It has a little bite to it.
It does.
I like it.
Thank you.
So the next up,
we have our Ghost Wheat,
which is a classic
American‐style wheat beer.
So, next up,
we have our Redwood IPA,
and that's a classic
West Coast‐style IPA.
I'm gonna give this IPA
a 9 out of 10.
Pretty good.
Awesome. Thank you.
And the only reason
it's not a 10
is the arrogance
of your valuation.
We'll get to
the arrogance.
We promise.
We'll get there.
We'll get there, Kevin.
Now we're on Chubby.
Kevin, they named this one
after you.
That's the Chubby Stout.
I really like this one.
Guys, how did you get into
the business in the first place?
So, first and foremost,
we love beer.
I was a home brewer
for 15 years.
And, you know, honestly,
we met at Cornell.
Brett and I were in
the business school together,
and we started the company
in an entrepreneurship class
at Cornell.
And it was for home‐brewing
temperature‐control devices.
You're Cornell MBAs?
Yes, sir.
Correct.
So break down the numbers
for me.
Sure.
So this costs us $375 to make.
And it retails for $499.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
It cost you $375 for all‐in,
all the pieces...
Yep.
...including a first ‐‐
one batch of consumables?
That's correct.
Delivered to your home.
And you sell it for?
$499.
How can you sell it so cheap?
That's no margin.
Right. Right.
So, we have
two revenue streams.
One is the machine
and one is the MKR Kit.
I get the replacement
of consumables and all that.
What we want to do
is we make sure
we get as many machines
out in the public as possible.
Okay. That's fine. So we'll
go into the consumables.
Exactly.
Yep. Yep. Exactly.
So the consumable side
of things,
it costs us $9 to $10
per ingredient kit.
At scale, we can get that down
to $7 per kit.
Is it a subscription,
just reorder?
We're encouraging our users to
go into a subscription system.
Okay. What's my monthly cost
for subscription?
$15 per 12‐pack.
What is your retention rate
of the subscriptions?
So, we're not there yet.
You mean you're not selling
any of these yet?
So, we are shipping them
literally ‐‐
MBA dudes!
I'm going to punish you!
We did our Kickstarter
in 2018,
and we're delivering
those 1,200 units
in the next two weeks.
How many have you shipped
so far?
We've shipped
about 24 of them.
So I should pay a million bucks
per unit you ship?
I'd just like to point out ‐‐
Had you shipped 50,
then you'd be worth $50 million.
[ Laughter ]
How much money have you raised?
We've raised about $3 million
so far.
There you go.
At what valuation?
You've got to be kidding.
Depending on the room, between
$5 million and $10 million.
It just makes no sense to me.
You ‐‐ It's like coming in
and asking us to believe
in the fairy godmother.
You have virtually no sales.
You have $3 million
put into it already,
and you have no proof
of concept, even.
I‐I must be missing
something basic, but I'm out.
We did have some proof
of concept when we kickstarted.
We sold 1,000 of these things
in one month.
And like I said,
this is a space ‐‐
But you haven't delivered them,
nor have you gotten
the feedback.
Greiner: Honestly,
you know, to Barbara's point,
the problem for me here is
everything tasted really good.
But because you haven't had
that in consumers' hands
and I don't know
what's gonna happen,
I can't invest at this point.
I'm sorry.
I'm out.
Look, what you're setting out
to do is right on.
Sure.
The challenge
is your margins.
Because you're going to have to
really retain people.
And I think that's gonna be
a lot more expensive.
And even if the valuation is
in the realm of where you're at,
it's gonna be hard
to generate enough profits
to give me a return.
And so for those reasons,
I'm out.
Well, to address those
particular points, I'd love ‐‐
He's out.
Address it with other Sharks.
Rodriguez: Aaron, brother,
let me tell you this.
First of all,
one piece of advice
is when you come in the Tank,
you have to make it attractive
for us to make some money.
Yeah.
When you come in here
and you say $500,000 for 2%,
five of us got turned off.
So for me, valuation ‐‐
very competitive,
and we don't know
what we don't know.
For those reasons, I'm out.
[ Dramatic music plays ]
Kevin.
O'Leary:
I'm a reasonable man...
[ Laughs ]
We love you,
Mr. Wonderful.
...and I like to give,
particularly for entrepreneurs,
that at the end of the day,
the product is excellent.
You have not heard anybody say
this beer isn't great.
Absolutely.
And I consider myself
a connoisseur
of all things
with alcohol in them.
[ Chuckles ]
My inner instinct
is to eviscerate you.
But I'm not gonna do that
because ‐‐
We appreciate that.
I think it's so interesting.
So how do I encapsulate
this ridiculous valuation
but still be a partner
with you?
Royalties!
Now, let me show you
how to do it.
No royalty at all.
No royalty.
Okay. Okay.
I just take what I do in the
wine business and apply it here.
$500,000.
It's debt.
I'll do it at 9%.
Told you.
36 months straight debt,
which you can afford if you
believe your numbers, okay?
And I want 4% equity.
You can figure out ‐‐
Stay out of the cap table.
That's not a bad deal.
Give them to me
as advisory shares.
I would do that deal, and you
should seriously consider it,
because you're not gonna get
a deal from anybody else.
There's an offer.
What do you want to do?
Well, would you be able to go
for 2% with the debt?
I'll do it at 3%.
I'll meet you in the middle.
[ Suspenseful music plays ]
I have an MBA, too,
unfortunately.
We're really worried about
the working‐capital implications
of that.
I don't want to fight with you
about valuation.
We're never going to agree.
Rodriguez: So, Kevin,
let me give it a crack.
$500,000 and 9%
is $3,750 a month.
You guys feel
you can cover that?
That's not a lot of money.
Rodriguez:
That's nothing, right?
We ‐‐ Yeah.
We could cover that.
The problem, though, is after
we're done paying that back,
we'd have had to pay back
$500,000
plus 9% over three years.
Yeah. That's why ‐‐
Yes.
Right, in which case, it's ‐‐
We're still now ‐‐
But you have a partner
that millions of people know
and trust in these beverages.
If you don't want to do it,
don't do it.
♪♪
I'm afraid
that we're not comfortable
with the debt portion.
I'm okay. Thank you.
I'm...
I'm out.
All right.
Thank you, everyone.
Okay.
Congratulations
on what you've done, though.
I'll look forward to it.
All right.
Thank you. Thank you.
Thanks, guys.
Good luck, guys.
Bye‐bye.
‐Thank you.
‐Take care.
♪♪
Wow.
Yeah.
Oh, man.
That was ‐‐
Yeah. That was unexpected.
Yeah.
A little bit.
Ultimately,
we believe in our product,
we believe in our team,
and this is gonna be a big deal.
So, you know, maybe the Sharks
made a big mistake.
♪♪